hello YouTube Chancellor's my friends
this is grunge in here welcome to this
video now I know a lot of you come over
here by just reading the title and many
of you are the fan of Magnus Carlsen so
the first thing I need to clarify over
here is the purpose of this video is not
to offend Magnus Carlsen his fan club or
his countrymen I myself is a big fan of
Carlsen and by showing you this video I
want to illustrate a important point
that even the world's best has bad days
in their life and as a chess player
if you remain positive and play good
chess on the board then you can outplay
them now looking at the Magnus Carlsen
and his talent there's always squishin
comes into the mind that is this Mozart
of chess ever lost a game very quickly
so I'm not talking about over here like
his blitz game or the rapid game but I'm
talking about his classical game where
both the side has ample time to think
about their game and still loses in
let's say under 25 or 20 moves well I
have done some research on this and I
found out that the quickest lost for the
Magnus was within 15 moves shocking
right but it's true well you may think
where Magnus was young this game was
happened well that's not the case the
worst part is when this game was played
Magnus was already a GM let's see how
all this happened
polity start with the d4 and Magnus
responds with the move Knight to f6 and
after the move c4 magnus plays his pet
line nimzo-indian
with the movie six white goes with the
main line that is Knight to c3 and
Bishop to b4 happened on the ball now
because this game is very short I'm
going to conduct a training exercise for
you so what you have to do is at certain
point I'll ask you to pause the video
and find out the move of the white and
if your move match with the move played
in the game then you have to score 10
points but if your move haven't matched
with the game then you just have to give
0 points at the end we are going to
calculate your points and let's see you
have the potential of beating ball
spaced ok first critical point I like
you to pause this video and find out
what is the best reply by white okay I
hope you find this move that is Queen to
c2
it is a dual-purpose move where Queen
not only protecting the knight and do
not allow a double pawn but it also
stopping Knight to e4 idea Carlsen
continue here with the MU D Phi now D
Phi is considered to be the most
sharpest line against Queen to c2
variation apart from the D Phi other
moves are Castle on the King side or C
Phi these are the modern moves but D Phi
says it said that calcine wants to very
sharp game and he is playing for the win
here why took this pawn and now comes
the surprising gambit C Phi now this is
a very tricky move and white should know
exactly what he is going to do about it
before one year I had this line in my
recruiter and I had a very mixed result
in my game my opponent who doesn't know
how to handle this line I get some
amazing victories but on the other hand
the opponent's who knows how to handle
this line I had a lot of struggle so
it's a very double-edged line now comes
the second critical moment of the game
kindly pause the video and find out how
you going to continue from this position
okay I hope you find this smooth that is
d capture c5 now instead of D capture C
Phi if white wants to be greedy and hang
on to his pawn then he can continue with
the move D capture c6 but this is
exactly black ones because after Queen
captures pawn captures and Bishop
captures you can already see Black has
four pcs in the game and just for the
one pawn this is a tremendous
compensation now
after D capture c5 black plays Knight
captures d5 so if allowed then black
will certainly double White's pawn so
white has to stop this so white plays
the move Bishop to d2 and now black get
his material back after Bishop captures
c5 now comes the third important move
this is very crucial because we already
reached to the half point of the game
and it doesn't look like white is doing
anything so my question is how you going
to continue congratulations if you find
this wonderful move that is Knight
captures defy the point is black cannot
capture with the pawn because his bishop
is hanging so black has to forcefully
capture with his queen and then fight is
going to play this move which you need
to identify which move white was aiming
for okay I hope you find this move that
is e foe
so it's a developing move with the tempo
because now again black has to move his
Queen somewhere and white is getting his
initiative as for the computer the best
move over here is either Queen to c6 or
Queen to g6 but in the game as the
Carlsen was feeling very aggressive he
played the move Queen to d4 ball is in
your court how you going to continue I
hope you find this wonderful move that
is castle on the Queen side
what a wonderful move to play Black has
some severe difficulties because you can
already see this bishops are loose and
White has a simple threat now of Bishop
to e3 and nabbing the piece so black has
to respond very accurately which in fact
calcine did so calcine played over here
Knight to
d7 so protecting both the bishop now
instead of Knight to d7
if black become greedy and play moves
such as Queen to f2 then after Knight to
h3 attacking the Queen and Queen to d4
and Bishop to g5 the game is over
because black has to give up the Queen
as if the Queen moves away then rook to
b8 alludes to the checkmate so black has
to play very precise moves after 97 now
comes the move of the game can you spot
White's next reply okay I hope you find
this smooth that is Bishop to b5 once
again white is renewing the threat of
pinning this Knight and thus threatening
Bishop to e3 and nabbing the piece so
again black has to play very precise
moves and I think at this precise moment
Carlsen failed to spot the danger in the
position and this is a very good example
that if you pressurize your opponent
then even one of the best in the world
can get annoyed and played a bad move
under pressure castle plays this
horrific blunder that is castle on the
Kings side now before proceed I like to
point out the danger in this position so
for example let's say black continue
over here with the MU a6 then comes
Bishop to e3 attacking the Queen and
after Queen to e5 we can simply capture
this Bishop kindly note not Bishop
captures d7 because after Bishop
captures Bishop captures and rook to see
eight black regain his material with an
advantage so that's why in this position
Bishop captures c5 is a most accurate
move because after pawn captures Bishop
to d6 Queen check and King to b1 why
it's wonderful Bishop has stopped black
to castle on the Kings side that means
black King will remain in the center and
in fact if you verify this position with
the engine
it will give good amount of advantage to
the white now amazingly enough black and
still survive from this position and the
best move over here is Bishop to e7
afterward the sample line can run like
this so Bishop to e3 Queen to b4 Queen
to a4 and after Queen captures Bishop
captures and a6
this position is equal I think the only
reason Carlsen done the castle because I
definitely think that he only considered
the move Bishop to e3 where he created a
nasty trap so let's see this so if white
played over here Bishop to e3 which is a
blunder move because of the following
sequence that is Queen to b4 Bishop
captures Bishop captures with a check
and after pawn captures and Bishop
captures white cannot capture this
Bishop s after rook captures d7 rook to
c8 skewering queen and a king and if I
try to save the Queen after rook to c7
then that comes Queen to even check
Queen to d1 rook captures Czech and
after keen to b1 and Queen captures d1
it's a checkmate so now the big question
is on your side what is wrong with the
MU Castle okay I hope you find this
wonderful move that is Bishop to c3 and
black is busted the simple reason is
this Queen has no space to go the only
move left over here is Queen captures f2
which is played in the game but after
Queen captures Bishop captures and
Bishop captures d7 black played a token
check that is Bishop to e3 and after
keen to see to Carlson realized that he
is a piece down for not a single
compensation so at this point
here is signed so there you have it a
simple but effective play by white
putting black in lot of pressure and
shows us that even world's greatest can
be knocked down by playing accurate
moves now it's time to calculate your
points if you score more than 60% then
definitely you have the potential of
becoming a good chess player and if you
score less than that then you are not
looking at the right direction and you
need some improvement well thank you for
watching this video feel free to like
subscribe and comment on my video and
I'll meet you in my next episode very
soon bye and take care
I hope you find this move that is Queen
- eh AK boom boom so sacrificing the
whole Queen these are two very very
effective plants by the wild and please
note why it has a tremendous space
advantage because of this c4 and d4 news